I cannot believe you're not stepping
with us this year I've got to focus on
getting into Harvard there's a video
online
the Sigma Beta Beta member having sex on
their lawn
you need to make SPB look like positive
contributors to the community don't you
with a big charity step competition
coming up why do you make this SBB mess
go away and I will guarantee you
admission to Harvard I think I have a
way to save your Charter and get you
reinstated do it compete in a charity
step show country lap dancer but
surprise is no one stepping requires an
extraordinary amount of discipline we
don't drink during I'm seen enough
you're not teaching them are you Jim go
you crazy my sorors fine too huh
teaching you to sin is gonna get ugly
ugly
[Music]
the shade it is real respects you guys
because you don't respect each other you
build up the sisterhood I promise you
have a real shot I said hell yeah your
sisterhood is your bond do not let it
break are you guys feeling out of place
like maybe they're judging you before
you've had a chance to express
yourselves you're in this position for
ten minutes you can drown in a pool
white girl tears are you gonna cowboy
[Music]
I'm from Kappa next or you shook our
house we lost a row of totally
irreplaceable shot
you